LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
dormir le jour pour travailler la nuit
c'est le quotidien d'un salarié sur 10
en France les horaires atypiques le son
de moins en moins pourtant notre
organisme n'est pas adapté à un tel
rythme
j'ai compris que
en fait il y avait une réelle pénibilité
il y avait un réel impact sur le corps
et que et que très vite il fallait que
je trouve des petites astuces pour que
mon corps comprenne très vite le rythme
et surtout qu'il soit le moins perturbé
possible lorsque l'horloge interne se
dérègle les conséquences peuvent être
graves c'est un médecin qui m'a dit
cancer du sein et travail de nuit ça va
ensemble alors pourquoi notre rythme
veille sommeil est-il aussi important
comment mieux prendre en compte notre
horloge biologique alors que tout
s'accélère autour de nous c'est le thème
de ce nouveau numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d'état de santé avec la rentrée
de septembre voilà fini les grasses
mattes fini les repas tardifs on change
de rythme on entre dans des rythmes
journaliers plus réguliers est-ce que
c'est mieux est-ce que c'est moins bien
on va se pencher sur une problématique
passionnante aujourd'hui comment vous le
rythme des journées sur notre santé on
va explorer ça avec vous bonjour Hélène
dièse bonjour vous êtes chronobiologiste
chercheuse en rythme on va le voir dans
un instant mais évidemment quand on est
quand on respire pour la première fois
on va dormir beaucoup et puis au fil de
la vie ce rythme là interne il va
évoluer donc on a une horloge interne
qui évolue tout au long de la vie on a
une horloge interne on a un petit
mécanisme qui existe à l'intérieur de
toutes nos cellules tous nos organes et
qui nous permet de mesurer le temps qui
passe et ça nous permet de nous adapter
à cette alternance jour nuit qui est
engendrée par la rotation de de la terre
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un rythme
circadien d'ailleurs c'est quoi alors
circadien ça veut dire
environ une journée ça vient du latin
circa Diem environ une journée donc ça
veut dire que c'est un rythme d'environ
24 heures pas exactement 24 heures notre
horloge interne n'est pas en tout cas
chez l'homme ne génère pas un rythme de
24 heures piles et donc on a besoin
d'une rose synchronisation chaque jour
pour remettre en face notre horloge
passionnant vous êtes chronobiologiste
en regardant votre parcours
[Musique]
Hélène Duez et directrice de recherche
en chronobiologie à l'INSERM et à
l'Institut Pasteur de Lille depuis 20
ans elle tente de comprendre comment et
pourquoi notre métabolisme est contrôlé
par notre horloge biologique son
objectif à terme et de s'appuyer sur ses
découvertes pour mieux prendre en charge
des pathologies comme le diabète les
maladies cardiovasculaires ou
inflammatoires
[Musique]
Hélène vs vous nous disiez on a une
horloge interne qui évolue tout au long
de la ville mais il y a aussi ce soleil
qui se lève à une certaine heure le
matin l'hiver et notre heure l'été et en
quoi ça interagit avec notre horloge
interne et c'est ce signal de lumière
qu'on a le matin cette lumière bleue qui
est mise par le soleil qui va jouer ce
rôle de remettre notre horloge à l'heure
tous les jours c'est comme si on montait
notre montre exactement ça nous permet
de redémarrer parce que la lumière grâce
à l'horloge biologique qui sert de
relais va engendrer toute une série de
changements et notamment un pic de
cortisol qu'on a le matin et qui va
permettre de mettre en phase tous nos
organes toutes nos cellules il faudrait
des qu'on se lève sortir dehors et être
exposé au jour alors ce serait bon pour
nous ce serait bon pour nous ce serait
bon pour nous parce que ça permettrait
de renforcer ce rythme là alors c'est
pas parce qu'on n'est pas exposé à la
lumière le matin qu'on perd son rythme
mais ça le renforce alors il y a des
choses passionnantes avec cette horloge
interne ce qui a eu des expériences qui
ont montré que quand on a ni le jour ni
la nuit ce rythme de 24 heures il survit
à l'absence de lumière infographie
[Musique]
en 1962 un spéléologue français a eu une
drôle d'idée Michel cyphe a passé deux
mois à 130 mètres de profondeur dans un
gouffre en Italie
son objectif voir comment son rythme
veille sommeil allait évolué sans repère
temporel il est en effet descendu sans
montre ni agenda et avec une petite
lampe électrique pour seule lumière
coupée de l'extérieur il disposait tout
de même d'une ligne téléphonique pour
rappeler une équipe de veille en surface
à chaque réveil chaque coucher et chaque
repas ses horaires étaient ainsi
consignés
Michel ciffre se levait se coucher et
manger quand il le voulait
il a peu à peu perdu la notion du temps
pensant que ces journées ne duraient pas
plus de 5 heures mais en remontant à la
surface après deux mois il a fait une
découverte historique
son cycle veille sommeil n'avait subi
aucun changement
chaque jour il avait dormi environ 8h30
et veiller 16 heures en tout 24 heures
l'humain a donc bien une horloge interne
qui règle l'organisme même en dehors de
toute contrainte en revanche ce rythme
était un peu plus long que celui de la
rotation de la Terre chaque jour dans sa
grotte Michel Siffre se couchait et se
réveillait une demi-heure plus tard se
décalant progressivement
c'est pourquoi la lumière du jour est si
importante elle nous sert de signal et
nous permet d'être tous synchronisés sur
un même rythme de 24 heures
[Musique]
en quoi cette expérience quand même
extraordinaire est intéressante elle est
intéressante parce qu'elle montre la
nature endogène de notre horloge
biologique elle montre que en absence de
tout signal notre horloge biologique
continue de générer un rythme donc notre
horloge interne est plus puissant
que le jour et la nuit que nous impose
la nature c'est extravagant elle est
très puissante parce que c'est un
ensemble de protéines qui modifie
l'expression de nos gènes de notre
patrimoine génétique dans chacune de nos
cellules donc ça c'est vraiment un rôle
crucial alors il y a en revanche quelque
chose qui est pénalisant et on va le
voir dans le reportage dans un instant
de Marianne gazou c'est quand on est à
l'envers c'est à dire quand on vit un
rebours du jour et de la nuit là on l'a
secoue notre horloge interne on la
secoue on la secoue énormément on la
secoue un manque de sommeil ou par
décalage par rapport au jour et la nuit
les deux les deux donc et les deux sont
les deux sont vraiment deux composantes
importantes on la secoue par un
troisième facteur qui est que à côté de
la lumière
rapport à laquelle on mange est aussi un
signal très fort pour nos horloges et en
mangeant à une heure qui n'est pas
propice on dérègle aussi nos horloges
donc il y a ils sont vraiment les trois
facteurs que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
qui font que le travail de nuit ou le
travail en horaires décalé n'est pas bon
pour notre horloge biologique alors pour
état de santé Mayenne gasoa donc
rencontrer ses travailleurs qui sont
exposés à ces assez rythmes décalés plus
ou moins décalés mais parfois totalement
quelles en sont aussi les conséquences
on regarde leur ce reportage on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
d'humains ne sont pas des animaux
nocturnes
Alice Dumont le sait bien pourtant cela
fait 8 ans qu'elle travaille la nuit et
dort le jour c'est le lot de nombreuses
infirmières comme elle le rythme de nuit
c'était un rythme que je connaissais pas
du tout je me suis dit pourquoi pas se
lancer je me suis rendu compte de tout
le temps libre que ça dégageait mais
comment fait-elle pour s'adapter un tel
mode de vie tous les matins elle
s'endort vers 8h30 en ce mois d'août il
fait déjà bien jour dehors et si Alice
Dumont a du temps libre c'est au prix de
son sommeil elle ne dort que 4 à 5
heures par jour je vois quand même une
différence avec le début déjà au niveau
du vieillissement de Napo les rides
prématurés qui sont apparus quand même
assez vite les cernes qui sont quand
même beaucoup plus mariés quand j'étais
au tout début de carrière je me demande
de plus en plus si c'est quelque chose
que j'arriverai à tenir dans la durée et
du coup je commence déjà à repenser à
des reconversions professionnelles enfin
si je devais arrêter
qu'est-ce que ça serait ma vie en fait
en attendant pour limiter les risques
sur sa santé Alice Dumont s'impose une
routine stricte pendant la journée elle
se lève et prend ses repas à heure fixe
mais elle manque souvent d'énergie pour
sortir s'exposer à la lumière du jour ou
faire du sport ce dont elle aurait
pourtant besoin
j'ai compris que
en fait il y avait une réelle pénibilité
il y avait un réel impact sur le corps
et que et que très vite il fallait que
je trouve des petites astuces voilà pour
pour que mon corps comprenne très vite
le rythme et surtout qu'il soit le moins
perturbé possible parce qu'il y a des
petites carences qui doivent se faire
même si on essaie de compenser avec de
la nourriture avec des fruits avec tout
ça il y a quand même des choses qui ne
se font plus ou que je dois plus avoir
de la même façon qu'avant
l'organisme subit les assauts d'une vie
décalée et les conséquences peuvent être
graves
à Saint Mitre les Remparts près de
Marseille Sylvie Pioli est aujourd'hui à
la retraite après avoir exercé en tant
qu'infirmière de nuit pendant 30 ans
il y a quelques années en 2015 elle a
appris qu'elle souffrait d'un cancer du
sein à l'époque elle est tombée des nues
antécédent de cancer du sol dans ma
famille j'ai une vie saine je fais
beaucoup de sport je bois pas je fume
pas
j'avais une ligne assez parfaite en fait
c'est un médecin qui m'a mis la puce à
l'oreille qui m'a dit
cancer du sein et travail de nuit ça va
ensemble et de là j'ai effectué des
recherches elle découvre alors cette
étude de l'Inserm qui montre qu'il
existe bel et bien un lien entre les
deux le risque de cancer du sein est
augmenté d'environ 30% chez les femmes
ayant travaillé de nuit par rapport aux
autres femmes
la pression d'avoir été trahie parce que
Ben personne ne nous l'avait dit si
j'avais été prévenu et bien j'aurais
fait un peu plus attention à mon hygiène
de vie peut-être
j'aurais un peu plus
dormir parce que je dormais très peu
surtout en l'an dernier et puis j'aurais
peut-être aussi arrêter de grignoter la
nuit ce qu'on fait à peu près tous alors
qu'on sait très bien que l'alimentation
est très importante ça me motive
justement pour qu'il ait de plus en plus
de gens qui soient au courant de ce
facteur de risque qui est très méconnu
aujourd'hui en rémission elle se bat
pour faire reconnaître son cancer du
sein en maladie professionnelle une
reconnaissance accordée pour la première
fois en mars 2023 à une infirmière
mosellane
Sylvie Pioli à bon espoir que les choses
changent et elle fait tout pour se faire
entendre des décideurs elle a créé
l'association cyclossin pour
sensibiliser à cette cause de manière
originale alors là c'est quand on était
à Bruxelles comme si on obéenne le grand
départ de saint-mitre-les-rempart pour
Paris 1104 km notre arrivée à Paris
devant le ministère de la Santé
elle a même pédalé jusqu'à
l'Organisation internationale du travail
à Genève en attendant un meilleur suivi
du personnel de nuit Sylvie Pioli par
sensibiliser les lycées et les écoles
d'infirmières sur les routes de France
[Musique]
c'est impressionnant ce reportage on
précise que 10% des salariés sont
exposés à des horaires complètement
complètement décalés à l'envers en tout
20% vivent à des horaires plus ou moins
décalées est-ce que vous diriez que
quand on travaille de cette façon de
nuit sur évidemment un temps long il
faut aller voir un spécialiste du
sommeil oui je pense qu'il faut se faire
accompagner par un spécialiste du
sommeil mais pas que parce qu'en fait il
y a des choses qui peuvent être mises en
place une exposition à la lumière au bon
moment peut aider à recaler notre
horloge éviter la lumière à d'autres
moments par exemple porter des lunettes
de soleil quand on sort du travail s'il
fait jour dehors avant d'aller dormir il
y a beaucoup d'éléments qui sont pas
toujours connus des travailleurs en
horaires décalé et qui pourraient
améliorer ou en tout cas permettre de
lisser un petit peu les conséquences de
ce travail posté à condition évidemment
qui ne dure pas concerne toute une vie
essayez d'avoir des une forme de
régularité dans la prise de nourriture
par exemple ça c'est important c'est
important éviter on le voyant le
reportage de grignoter tout le temps ça
a l'air un peu dérisoire comme ça vous
dites non en fait ah non ça n'est pas du
tout dérisoire et ça l'est d'autant
moins que chez les travailleurs postés
il y a une envie plus forte d'éléments
riches en calories riche en sucre type
barre de céréales et évidemment quand
c'est sur deux ou trois jours c'est pas
très grave quand c'est surtout une vis
ça participe aux conséquences néfastes
de ce travail posté en finalement
augmentant le risque de maladies
métaboliques d'obésité donc ça ce sont
des choses sur lesquelles on peut agir
quand on voit qu'il y a une relation de
causalité entre un rythme de nuit et
l'apparition d'un cancer du sein c'est
surtout des cancers dont on est à peu
près sûr qu'il y ait un lien de cause
que vous avez fait il y a pas d'autres
pathologies qui ont été pointées du
doigt le risque est avéré aussi pour le
le développement de maladies
métaboliques obésité diabète peut-être
un petit peu moins clair pour les
maladies cardiovasculaires néanmoins
tous les éléments scientifiques que l'on
a que ce soit de recherche fondamentales
chez l'animal dans les cellules ou sur
les études épidémiologiques chez l'homme
tendent vers une augmentation du risque
de maladies cardiovasculaires également
on a besoin de personnes qui travaillent
la nuit on en a besoin mais néanmoins on
s'interroge est-ce que on est
suffisamment informé du risque en termes
de santé publique quand on nous fait
signer un accord ou un contrat de
travail de nuit il y a pas marqué en
tête attention en tout état de cause si
dans votre famille il y a un risque de
cancer du sein vous êtes exposé
particulièrement c'est vrai je pense
qu'il y a un manque d'informations il y
a une manque de transmission par la
médecine du travail par les employeurs
mais il y a aussi une méconnaissance
finalement
de ces données par par nous par nous
tous par le grand public on a commencé
l'émission en disant que
on dort pas de la même façon et au même
rythme selon qu'on est bébé ado et
personne âgées alors justement les ados
par beaucoup les ados ils sont décalés
ils se couchent à 4h du matin ils se
lève à midi c'est grave docteur
en fait c'est une évolution tout à fait
normale les jeunes enfants se lèvent
très tôt et se couchent très tôt ensuite
l'adolescence décale complètement vers
la fin vers l'après-midi vers la fin
d'après-midi la soirée quand on est à
l'âge adulte
des facto aussi parce qu'on a une
activité sociale on revient à un horaire
peut-être plus précoce et puis chez le
sujet âgé on voit bien des personnes
âgées souvent qui sont plus précoces le
matin qui se lèvent plus tôt qui ont
d'ailleurs un sommeil peut-être un petit
peu plus léger un peu plus fragmenté
donc une évolution tout à fait normale
et c'est pas c'est pas néfaste pour la
santé le problème c'est qu'on s'oblige
adolescent personne adulte etc à tous
vivre au même rythme mais néanmoins
certaines expériences pilotes ont été
réalisées outletic au Canada et aux
États-Unis ou des certaines écoles
démarre à 10 ou 11h le matin
le rêve pour les étudiants c'est une
expérience des expériences ce sont des
excès dégénéralisations non il y a pas
de généralisation mais dans ces
expériences très souvent les adolescents
ont vraiment bénéficié et les les
performances je dirais scolaires ont été
largement augmentés parce qu'on respecte
le rythme et puis que finalement les
filles étudiés au moment où ils sont
réceptifs à ce qu'on leur apprend c'est
une meilleure prise en compte de ces
rythmes naturels est-ce que vous diriez
il s'agit pas de se mettre descendre sur
la tête mais quand même que plus on va
moins on respecte les rythmes les temps
modernes sont plus pénalisant pour notre
horloge interne ils sont plus
pénalisants tout simplement parce que on
a aujourd'hui un éclairage qui nous
permet de rester actif toute la soirée
une partie de la nuit
par exemple on s'expose à des téléphones
portables qui ont une lumière LED bleu
comme celle qui recycronise notre
horloge le matin en tout cas les
médecins cherchent de plus en plus à
prendre en compte ces rythmes circadiens
dans la préconisation des soins
reportage Marianne Cazaux
[Musique]
pour traiter un cancer du pancréas cela
passe souvent par une chimiothérapie
mais dans ce service d'oncologie
digestive et médical de l'AP-HP bonjour
les médecins comptent aussi sur un outil
plus inhabituel un capteur qui
enregistre les rythmes circadiens du
patient chaque minute à distance ça
c'est votre rythme de température donc
on voit qu'il est vraiment très très
régulier
après une phase initiale où il était
plus perturbé ça c'était il y a cinq
jours à peu près d'accord le moment où
j'étais le plus mal après la chimio
d'activité repos il est vraiment parfait
pour Francis Levy c'est loin d'être
anecdotique avant que les symptômes ne
se manifeste on va voir se dégrader ces
paramètres du rythme et donc chez c'est
des signaux précoches
d'altérations de
l'état de santé de la personne
se télémonitoring est aujourd'hui à
l'étude
mais Francis Levy à bon espoir qu'il
prévienne à l'avenir les
hospitalisations d'urgence des patients
ce chronobiologiste n'en est pas à sa
première recherche sur les rythmes cela
fait 50 ans qu'il est persuadé que la
médecine doit mieux les prendre en
compte en 2000 il a montré que face au
cancer du côlon les patients qui avaient
un bon rythme biologique avec une
meilleure espérance de vie que les
autres
en 2002 il a mis en évidence pour la
première fois qu'en détruisant l'horloge
circadienne de souris et en leur
inoculant une tumeur celle-ci possède
deux à trois fois plus vite
on a découvert ensuite que ces gens-là
elles étaient pas seulement dans le
cerveau mais elles étaient aussi dans
toutes les cellules de tous nos organes
et puis s'il y a des maladies assez
riches perturber les horloges sont mal
synchronisées elles donnent des heures
différentes selon les cellules ou selon
les organes et il y a un risque de
développement de pathologies qui
survient les cellules tumorales aussi
peuvent avoir un rythme alors Francis
Lévy a décidé d'utiliser ses horloges
dans le traitement des cancers on avait
conscience que la que l'administration
des traitements selon le rythme
circadien ou que la détection de
perturbation du rythme circadien ouvrait
un nouveau pan de progrès pour la
médecine mais on n'était pas nombreux à
le penser on m'a demandé si j'étais
devenu astrologue bon j'ai rien contre
le astrologue mais enfin c'est pas mon
métier
mais Francis Levy a fini par convaincre
d'autres médecins comme Sylvie jacquetti
qui a travaillé à ses côtés il y a 30
ans aujourd'hui elle publie des
résultats enthousiasmants sur le
traitement du cancer du sein on a montré
que chez les femmes plus jeunes non
ménopausées donc celles qui prennent
l'hormonothérapie qui s'appelle le
tamoxifène et bien l'horaire de prise
est fondamentale puisque les patientes
qui prennent le tamoxifène le soir la
courbe verte ont un risque de rechute
qui est moindre que les patientes qui
prennent le tamoxifène le matin
lorsqu'elle prescrit ce médicament elle
ne manque donc pas d'indiquer le
meilleur moment pour le prendre
[Musique]
les traitements dans son service sylvie
jacquetti a également demandé aux
infirmières de bien noter l'heure
d'administration des autres traitements
sur le logiciel d'accord le bon horaire
sur le logiciel qu'on puisse utiliser
que les données informatiques super donc
c'est peut-être un petit effort mais
finalement on peut pas laisser on ne
peut pas faire que ça ne se fasse pas
pour la qualité des soins la structure
sarcadienne doit être présente parce
qu'elle fait partie de nous être humain
de la façon dont nous sommes structurés
mais ailleurs en France les rythmes
biologiques sont rarement utilisés dans
les soins d'autant plus que les
spécialistes doivent encore relever un
défi important celui de la
personnalisation car ces cycles
dépendent de nombreux facteurs comme
l'état général du patient l'âge ou le
sexe sur ce graphique nous voyons les
heures optimales d'administration en
fonction des différentes toxicités il
faut lire ce graphique comme une horloge
les flèches pointent vers les horaires
optimaux d'administration donc pour le
pour les hommes on est plutôt autour du
matin vers 9 heures du matin et pour les
femmes on est sur des horaires
d'administration optimaux plutôt vers 3
heures de l'après-midi donc on a une
différence de 5 heures entre les hommes
et les femmes des différences canabelles
balista doit prendre en compte dans ces
modèles le chemin vers la médecine
circadienne est encore longue mais
mathématicien et médecins tous en sont
persuadés il est grand temps de
l'emprunter
[Musique]
aussi c'est assez impressionnant de
l'impact que peut avoir sur l'organisme
malade l'horaire auquel on s'administre
les médicaments oui ces spectaculaire
mais en fait c'était presque attendu
même si on l'a découvert que très tard
tout simplement parce que les
médicaments vont cibler des processus ou
des protéines qui sont eux-mêmes très
souvent circadiens une question très
grand public
l'horaire d'été l'horaire d'hiver on
change toujours d'horaire c'est une
décision européenne alors qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous faut arrêter avec ça
l'idéal ce serait d'arrêter le
changement d'heure évidemment et puis
l'idéal ce serait d'avoir leur divers
qui nous permettrait de nous décaler
moins par rapport à leur solaire oui
vous êtes certaine que chaque fois ça
dérègle un peu nos organismes je pense
qu'effectivement chez un sujet sain ce
décalage d'une heure et bien on s'y fait
au bout de quelques jours c'est pas si
dramatique que ça par contre on voit par
exemple une recrudescence des cas
d'infarctus du myocarde juste après le
changement d'heure parce que l'infarctus
du myocarde on le sait il est beaucoup
plus fréquent le matin pour parce que
notre organisme est
circadien et quand on décale notre
horaire d'une heure et bien d'un seul
coup on augmente encore un petit peu
plus l'environnement néfaste pour notre
cœur et pour nos artères donc il y a il
y a des des catégories de la population
lesquels ce changement d'heure a
vraiment un impact on va revenir au
travail de nuit parce que vous savez
dans cette émission la tradition c'est
de poser une question un députée un élu
de l'Assemblée nationale Adrien Clouet
député de la France insoumise nups de
Haute-Garonne et vous avez voulu
l'interroger sur des méthodes des
mesures de prévention pour la santé pour
les personnes qui travaillent en horaire
décalé et on écoute sa réponse
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a une progression du
travail de nuit ça fait des années que
le code du travail est détricoté qui a
de plus en plus de travailleurs de nuit
les examens médicaux dans le monde du
travail ont reculé là aussi depuis
plusieurs années nous on se défend le
rétablissement d'un examen médical avant
l'embauche et périodique durant la
carrière donc déjà il faut surveiller de
manière aléatoire faire en sorte que les
gens passent régulièrement dans des
tests des différents examens pour être
sûr qu'ils n'ont pas un pépin il faut
bien sûr indemniser travail de nuit il
faut que l'heure de nuit soit plus payé
parce qu'il y a un préjudice il doit
être reconnu mais il faut aussi
évidemment limiter dans la carrière il
faudrait qu'on ait un nombre d'années
maximum qu'on puisse travailler de nuit
que le travail de nuit dans le lieu par
exemple à des bonifications pour les
semestres pour partir plus tôt à la
retraite bref il faut réorganiser la vie
des salariés qui exercent de nuit parce
qu'il y a des acides il y a des
activités police pompiers hospitaliers
où on a besoin de travail de nuit mais
il faut une compensation forte en termes
de santé donc des jours de repos accrus
un départ plutôt en fin de carrière une
limitation dans la carrière du travail
de nuit et une rémunération juste et
digne
[Musique]
on parle de plus en plus du sommeil ça
aussi j'imagine que pour vous c'est un
progrès et on a observé pour conclure
une perte générale moyenne d'une heure
trente de sommeil de l'individu c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup les conséquences
elles sont un petit peu les mêmes que
celles du travail posté donc il y a
vraiment là quelque chose à faire après
le sommeil il faut essayer de se le
préserver le plus possible ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire un horaire régulier ça
veut dire éviter les écrans une heure
1h30 avant d'aller se coucher parce que
évidemment cette lumière avant de se
coucher alors qu'en général on se couche
en regardant son écran peut-être qu'il
faut reprendre un bon vieux livre je
vous entendre si je puis dire
c'est très compliqué parce
qu'effectivement c'est plutôt le
contraire qui se passe mais j'imagine
que vous avez à coeur de faire passer
ces messages qui sont de moins en moins
respectés mais peut-être demain on
laissera tomber les téléphones 1h30
avant d'aller se coucher merci
infiniment Hélène de les avoir été avec
nous
dans ce numéro d'état de santé à très
vite
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance vous
a présenté état de santé